This video is brought to you by keeps.
Wisecrack quarantine. Jared here,
it's been a while since HBO's Watchman concluded.
And many of you have noticed that we've been uncharacteristically quiet that's
because this show is dense. Sure.
It pretty overtly deals with race in America, but there's just so much going on.
It's rife with God complexes, illusions to the graphic, novel and characters,
reading very specific books like Ernest Hemingway's for whom the bell tolls.
It seems like nothing in this show is a coincidence and we really want it to get
it right.
So what is Watchman trying to say between the convoluted conspiracy is, well,
we've got an idea to quote our favorite blue man. Nothing ever ends.
What never ends let's find out welcome is wisecrack edition on the philosophy of
HBO's Watchman. And of course.
Spoilers ahead.
First, a shout out to keeps for sponsoring this video. A lot of, you know,
how much I like my hair and I appreciate the nice comments and some of the less
nice ones, either way. It's basically become part of my identity.
So I'm pretty much scared out of my mind about losing it.
And from what I've learned, prevention is the key.
Do you know that two out of three guys will experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35, the sooner you act, the more hair you can save,
enter keeps an affordable hair loss treatment plan that brings FDA approved
prescription and over-the-counter medication right to your door.
Keeps offers scientifically proven treatments that can combat the symptoms of
hair loss with keeps some men even experience hair regrow,
find out why keeps has more five-star reviews than any of its competitors.
And why nearly 100,000 men trusted for their hair loss prevention medication by
clicking the link in the description,
or by going to keep stock com slash wisecrack. If you use our link,
you can get 50% off your first order. So stop stressing and keep your hair.
And now back to the show, first, a quick recap,
Watchman takes place over 30 years after the events of Alan Moore and Dave
Gibbons graphic novel. So let's start there in the 1980s,
the United States and the USSR are on the verge of a Nial leading the world in a
nuclear apocalypse. So the world's smartest man, Adrian Vite.
Concocts a plan to avert the war through fear and sends a giant cyanic squid
to attack New York city killing millions. The squid,
the world believes is an invader from another dimension.
So everybody unites us one nuclear apocalypse averted.
The history of watchman's world is very different from our own before and after
the graphic novel, the United States won the Vietnam war.
Richard Nixon was never impeached.
Robert Redford becomes president and term limits have been abolished.
God. Robert Redford is still precedent.
Also Dr. Manhattan used his godlike intelligence to invent a bunch of
electronics, but people thought he was giving them cancer.
So now the world exists,
mostly devoid of things like cell phones and lithium batteries watch me and the
TV show picks up in modern day. Tulsa roar shack,
who in the graphic novel sent his journal detailing fights plot to a right-wing
newspaper has been mostly dismissed as a crank,
but his Vistage has been taken up by a group of white supremacists known as the
seventh cavalry. They've been terrorizing.
The police who have also taken up masks to shield their identity within this
literal race war is detective Angela, a bar,
a black woman who must learn about her family's past by ODing on her grandpa's
memory pills. Also, she, it is heavily implied.
It becomes God before we can grasp what the show means by.
We have to understand one of watchman's recurring motifs judgment,
more in Gibbons Watchman, invoke the Latin phrase,
who watches the Watchman to warn of the dangers of master vigilantes,
taking justice into their own hands.
That is what do people do with unfettered power. If you're the comedian,
you gleefully murder with a smiley badge,
because it's kind of funny in the show to be cruelty and tyranny of individuals
exerting their judgment outside the law is everywhere. Vite, callously,
disregards the life that exists to serve him, creating the creepiest. I'm sorry.
A father has ever conveyed to his daughter when he's put on trial for his
crimes.
The judges keen to note that a jury of one's peers is the cornerstone of a fair
trial before noting.
You are not his peers. I sucked.
I have taken the Liberty of assembling an alternative jury,
much more suited to the task.
The point being one is entitled to be judged by one's peers.
And while Vite might consider himself a quasi God above these creatures,
the judge considers him to be below humanity.
The whole problem with vigilante justice, especially of the masked variety,
is that they Rob people of the opportunity to be judged by the legal system or
their peers. But the show is not just interested in individual vigilantism,
but in the vigilantism of mobs in the show's first scenes,
a young will Reeves watches,
a film about a black sheriff who captures a white cattle,
thief and rebuts calls for mob justice, with a plea instead to trust the law.
This scene is interrupted and we're shown another kind of mob justice as white
Tolsons massacre,
their black neighbors after a black man was accused of assaulting a white woman.
One way to answer the question of vigilante violence is what the work of
sociologist, max WebVR,
who defines a state as an entity that claims the monopoly of the legitimate use
of physical force within a community. In other words,
I can't just go and rally my friends to beat up the guy who sold me a bootleg
copy of Pokemon gold, nor can I physically coerce him to give me a refund.
Instead,
I have to call the police who as agents of the state are allowed to use force in
carrying out the law.
This is the basic conflict between the U S government and our master adventurers
as the Kenai criminalized vigilantism,
but trusting the law and the state's of violence isn't as Reeves learns a
magical cure to the ills of the day.
You ain't gone get justice with a badge we'll raves.
You can't get it with that hood.
One way to understand this is through Michelle CO's proposition,
that politics is the continuation of war by other means Fuko was inverting.
The famous aphorism. That war is merely the continuation of politics.
By other means, if, for instance, the U S military,
his goal was to defeat the threat of Nazi-ism during world war II.
We can look at the politics of post-war Germany as a continuation of the allied
victory. As the country rapidly did not suffer. Of course,
the show explores a similar idea with Vietnam statehood as the police do the
role otherwise done by the U S military.
But the Wars don't always have to be fought with tanks and generals.
If we're to consider the historical armed suppression of America's black
community through lynchings firebombings, et cetera, as a kind of war,
then we can see how that war was institutionalized into politics. In Watchman,
the Tulsa race massacre is the war.
And much of what comes after is the politics seeking justice through the law,
by becoming a police officer will read soon learns.
Many of his colleagues are secret white supremacists shielding their allies from
arrest years later,
this relationship has made even more clear by Senator Joe keen,
who more or less admits that he started a race war to help his presidential
aspirations,
where he could use the full power of the law to keep America's minorities in
their place.
You're wrong about psych labs? We're not racist.
We're about restoring balance in those times when our country forgets the
principles upon which it was founded because the scales have Tim away
too far,
and it is extremely difficult to be a white man in America.
But well, before that,
he describes the tension between the police and the seventh cavalry as a managed
piece to achieve his ends.
I came down here and assumed the leadership of these idiots to prevent that from
happening again. And my butter judge did the same as chief of police.
Each of us managing our respective teams so that we could maintain the peace.
As Fuko writes,
the role of political power is perpetually to use a sort of silent war to
reinscribe that relationship of force and to reinscribe it and institutions,
economic inequalities language, and even the bodies of individuals,
even the members of Cyclops, implicitly share this view of politics,
but with themselves as the victims with Redford, as president,
the members of Cyclops feel that they've lost their war,
that policies like red foundations are just a way of,
as King describes putting the white man down.
First, he took her guns.
And then he made us say, sorry, over and over again,
sorry,
sorry for the alleged sins of those who died decades
before we were born, sorry for the color of our skin.
Watchman is not just about the dangers of vigilante justice,
whether from Lynch or war crime, committing comedians,
but about how war and violence can become embedded in the law.
And when violence gets embedded in the law,
it can often evade judgment as a result after all justice is
blind. Speaking of judgment,
if you weren't sure this was at the top of Damon Lindelof, mine,
there's one song that keeps coming up that you may have noticed during vites
trial.
[Inaudible].
That's the Lac remote. So from Mozart's Requiem,
let's translate those lyrics full of tears will be that day.
When from the ashes shall arise, the guilty man to be judged, therefore,
spare him, Oh God, you know,
just a song about being judged at the end of the week.
World.
It plays when lady true tells Angela, Dr.
Manhattan is in Tulsa when Wade discovers the Cyclops hideout,
but most notably plays when Blake arrests Vite. And he says,
who do you think you are? Hold judgment over me.
The point being whether godlike actual gods or just people dressed up like
Batman,
many of our characters feel like their fellow humans are inadequate to judge
them keen and true want to become God for just that reason. True,
because she thinks she can unilaterally solve the world's problems and keen
extensively to re-establish the glory days of white supremacy.
Vites unilateral decision to save the world from nuclear.
Pocalypse is unknown to the world and thus not capable of being judged.
I saved the world from nuclear Armageddon. John
shy from you and select few,
but he knows.
Two are the actions of captain metropolis, hooded justice, roar shack,
or lube guy, a mask in the world of Watchman shields.
It's wearer from the judgment of others,
which makes judge recitation of the Latin phrase,
who watches the Watchman to his mass police force. So incredibly ironic, please.
Custodian Ipsos, custodies.
Especially as they reply Sec,
plops, conspiracy aside Watchman.
Isn't shy about how such a culture quickly leads to an out of control police,
state, where torture and right lessness are the norm.
Yeah, we really don't have to do that with terrorists.
When certain kinds of violence become embedded in the law,
the state can effectively shield themselves from judgment.
Whether you're throwing someone in the trunk of.
Your car, there's a guy in my trunk or.
Exploding people's heads on behalf of the federal government.
But if hiding one's identity protects one from the judgment of their peers,
so can hiding one's history.
One of White's sources of power is his ability to hide his past crimes from the
public. He doesn't need a mask to avoid judgment,
but this idea isn't simply limited to Vite.
We learned through PDP via the supplementary HBO material as collected by agent
PD, that fog dancing,
a book vide reads in prison is about American soldiers who would dispose of
evidence of American war crimes.
He claims he reads because it's about loneliness,
but maybe he relates to the themes of covering up one's crimes.
[Inaudible].
If fight is hiding his history to avoid judgment,
who or what else is to fully grasp that we have to look at watchman's
one, true God, Dr. Manhattan, part two,
nothing ever ends while Dr. Manhattan isn't even seen until the penultimate
episode, his worldview is critical to understand the show in episode eight,
he explains his unique relationship to time.
It's not a flow of events from past to present,
but something he experiences simultaneously. Hello.
Ben for you 24 years,
41 days and 13 hours for me it's happening right
now. Yes, yes, sir.
With this premise,
the show cuts back and forth between the doctor's childhood fleeing the Nazis,
his meeting of Angela and their future together.
The show wants us to think about history like Dr.
Manhattan without the idea of before I don't.
Experience the concept of before.
In other words,
a view of history in which nothing ever ends history is not dead but
alive in our current moment.
And the show constantly explores how the past continues into the present.
We see the fictional events of the graphic novel trickle into every detail of
life in a nod to the final pages of the graphic novel,
Angela and her grandmother eat at a chain called burgers and Borsch,
a cultural melding made possible by the threat of extra dimensional annihilation
at a dinner party.
Kids make a game of reciting the U S presidents moving to where Watchman
history,
diverges and Nixon never resigns and is succeeded by Gerald Ford and Robert
Redford.
[Inaudible].
Relishes in the tiniest of details.
Imagining that Steven Spielberg made Schindler's list, not about the Holocaust,
but about the giant squid attack.
The move is black and white. So the red really pops, you know, um,
and the girls stumbling around Harold square,
walking under the tenant calls. They do all the dead bodies
and she's scared.
Or suggesting to the viewer that John Grisham has become a Supreme court
justice. Of course, if the alternate history gives way to the alternate present.
So two does real history giveaway to the real present.
Aside from small Easter eggs, it cannot be understated.
The insane level of detail Watchman puts into thinking about history.
Blake sidekick PD has a PhD in history.
I wrote my graduate thesis on the police strike of 77.
Will's wife. June is a reporter at the New York Amsterdam news.
Why are you writing?
You still worried about me because the Amsterdam says a Negro cadet making the
forces big news.
One of new York's most influential and oldest African-American newspapers that
was especially active in covering the civil rights movement and Chronicle
derives of X lady true is named after the Vietnamese historical figure who
fought to resist the Chinese state of Eastern Wu as it occupied Vietnam and is
quoted by her mother when she steals vites seed.
[Inaudible].
Events happen in a literal museum and the U S treasury secretary is real life
historian, Henry Louis Gates, Jr. And here we get back to Dr.
Manhattan because justice Manhattan's experience of time seamlessly jumps from
one moment in time to another. So too,
does the show like Manhattan laughing at a six month old joke?
This Angela must be quite something six months ago.
She's telling me I have a fantastic imagination.
The show interjects moments of history to show their connectedness.
The show often juxtaposes similar objects from different times.
This is most explicitly done while Angela is overdosing on the stall. Jo,
as Angela remembers being given a badge by a Vietnamese police officer,
the show quickly cuts to the badge of bass reads in the 1920s to will Reeves
receiving his badge over a decade later to the blood spattered badge of cheap
Crawford over half a century later,
when a police officer puts a sack over a suspect's head,
Angela flashes back to the memory of will putting on the sack from his almost
lynching, or as we'll read,
sees a police car drive by two corpses from the Tulsa race massacre drag behind
through these techniques.
The show asks the viewer to consider past and present acts of racism as one
continual legacy.
Other examples in the show are stretched out between episodes in Tulsa.
We see a Molotov cocktail thrown through a shop window and event that repeats
itself years later at a Jewish deli Angela's makeup closely resemble hooded
justices,
but it blackens her skin instead of a widening it and a racist bank ad we see
unveiled by captain metropolis is later hung in the seventh cavalry hideout,
much like the graphic novel.
The show uses the clock motif to ask the viewer to consider the idea of time and
how not.
Unlike a constructed watch is a series of meticulous cogs that create an
illusory March from past to present this counterintuitive approach to
time seems critical to one of watchman's biggest themes, historiography.
That is the writing of history,
but simply debates around historiography can let us ask questions like what is,
or was considered historically important enough to discuss in the first place.
A lot of history involves finding facts about individual events and discerning a
narrative in them. And that's where things can get especially tricky.
So was the Holocaust some anomaly of European history or was the
extermination of Jews gypsies and others deeply influenced by practices and
ideologies birthed by Europeans as they colonized Africa as Hunter or rent
or other historians argue same event,
different story watchman's own show within a show,
American hero story like the comics novel within a novel under the hood serves
as a reminder of what happens to history.
When sensationalism meets an utter disregard for the truth PDs complaints about
its accuracy aside that show.
It was garbage it's there it's full of historical.
It manages to tell the story of hooded justice while glibly ignoring the lack of
information about the person behind the mask. In this case,
what the show portrays is a fun romp of a robbery busting was actually a black
man fighting the clan to drive the point home the same,
more or less placed in reverse hinting. How the show got it in historical terms,
backwards,
rest fictional hooded justice breaks into the store from the window to save the
day from some nameless thugs.
The real hooded justice jumped out the window when fleeing from a prominent
white supremacist, much of the history of Watchman,
like its fictional critique of American hero story focuses on exactly what's
been forgotten or deliberately ignored in the mainstream writing of real
American history throughout the show were presented with events in newspaper
clippings.
That one might easily dismiss as part of the show's intricate mythology,
but time after time, they're not,
they actually happen who to justice has pinned up articles,
declaring Nazis March through streets of long Island and 22,000 Nazis hold
rally in Madison square garden.
The latter being a reference to the German American Bund rally in New York.
The insinuation is that support for Nazi-ism and America is intricately linked
to the fictional Cyclops with its white supremacist mission. Of course,
many people have discussed the show's opening,
which portrays the event of the Tulsa race massacre,
where America's wealthiest black neighborhood was destroyed by a mob of white
Tulsa. As NBC reported.
Many people were surprised to learn that this was in fact real,
as it is not often discussed in most history textbooks. Even the small details,
the presence of black GIS who had served in world war one in Tulsa and the
bombing by airplanes are all historically accurate. Later,
we see German propaganda during world war one that asks black GIS why they would
fight for a country in which they were second class citizens.
Do you enjoy the same rights as two white people in America
treated as second class citizens.
The leaflet,
which a young William finds in his father's coat reflects real German propaganda
from the time what's more a newspaper on the ground bears the real headline from
the Tulsa Tribune in the lead up to the massacre.
The article even makes its way to modern day as a scene in the Greenwood museum.
The museum is helmed, not only by a prominent historian,
but a man who sparked a national outrage about racial profiling after being
arrested for breaking into his own home. There's a pretty fitting moment.
When will Reeves confronts Judd about the Klan robe in his closet? Again,
the history is no accident. The clan often collaborated police departments,
especially during the civil rights era.
The Klan had helped elect a white racist named Eugene bull Connor as
Birmingham's police chief.
In Florida. For instance,
the FBI knew too that in the 1940s and fifties County sheriffs
openly joined the clan writes Gilbert King in his book devil in the Grove during
the Tulsa massacre itself,
some police officers straight up deputized members of the Lynch mob. Of course,
the regular involvement of police departments with Lynch mobs in the clan are
simultaneously either ignored or in Judd's case part of his heritage.
I have a right to keep it. It's my legacy to which William replies.
And you should feel proud of your legacy, what you hide it.
Goodbye America's history has been shielded from judgment. Alan Moore though.
He's had sharp words against the HBO show has made similar statements about the
history of masked heroes saying a good argument can be made for DW Griffith's
birth of a nation as the first American superhero movie and the point of origin
for all those capes and masks Griffith's film,
which glorified the clan is credited with helping the rebirth of the KKK in
America. Then of course there's the more subtle,
or maybe just coincidental historical parallels,
the Cyclops mesmerism encourages African-Americans to harm and hate each other.
To any white man woman or child.
It seems like a loose fictionalization of the idea as argued by thinker,
bell hooks that the entire world of advertising and mass media in general,
which sends both the covert and overt message that blackness is negative is part
of the propaganda machinery of shaming.
The seven cavalry members live in a place called Nixon bill,
obviously after the president,
but Nixon might be of specific importance to the show's fascination with
history.
Whereas pandering to white racists was a favorite pastime of Democrats like
George Wallace Nixon and his political allies were able to rest votes from the
traditionally Democrat voting South to the Republican party.
I stirring up racist fears and white voters to quote Nixon strategist,
Kevin Phillips in 1970, the more Negroes who register as Democrats in the South,
the sooner the Negro folk whites will quit the Democrats and become Republicans.
That's where the votes are.
The idea that the seventh cavalry are not some modern anomaly,
but the product of specific history is further driven home by smaller details.
Their name derives from the U S army regiment famously commanded by general
Custer during the great Sioux war of 1876,
a war brought on by America's desire for gold and native American territory.
At one point Judd even sends a pager message,
reading a little big horn in reference to Custer's famous last stand.
The idea that they're driven by the historical legacy of manifest destiny and
white supremacy in America is furthered with small details like the painting
marshal feats of Comanche horsemanship, uh, George Catlin, painting that in PD,
pedia we learn was given by Senator King to remind Jud how formidable our Savage
enemies can be.
The philosophy of Watchman might just be coyly written right there in the
episode four title. If you don't like my story,
write your own borrowing from a quote from author chin watch habit it's worth
mentioning a Chavez famous novel things fall apart is about the arrival of
European colonizers in Nigeria. A chubby has scholar.
John Tema notes was interested in recuperating the image of Africa in contrast
to European writers like Joseph Conrad,
who portrayed it as a place of savagery and barbarism through the character of
Angela.
We see watchman's approach to history as she learns the truth of her past and
how it is deeply affected her.
Her whole journey is as will describes it to learn where she came from.
Good morning to meet you and show you what you came.
She not only has to grapple with the trauma that defines her,
but how bad trauma seems rooted in her genealogy in a different episode.
Lady true tells to farmers that legacy isn't is.
It's in blood passed to us from our ancestors and bias.
Angela learns that the legacy she inherited was that of a granddaughter of a
Tulsa massacre survivor elsewhere.
We're told about genetic trauma in a support group.
There's this thing, genetic drama.
While these psychic squid mass murder is fictional.
The concept of genetic trauma is the real and ongoing hypothesis that stressful
or traumatic experiences might alter the genetic expression of their children.
Small studies of the children of Holocaust survivors. For instance,
it's just biological changes in their children,
but if squid survivors can beget their trauma to their kin in watchman's eyes.
So to can the victims of racist violence,
when Angela fully learns her history by taking the stall jet,
it almost breaks her mind, but by the end,
Angela learns not to suppress her personal trauma as will explains.
Anger
under a mask. Angela.
And what about Angela's heavily implied apotheosis for a show fixated on the
monstrous deeds of characters trying to become God.
It seems strange to have the protagonist become one,
but if we think back to time,
one of the shows primary motifs and how Dr. Manhattan experiences it,
maybe Angela's arc is to experience the past,
present and future as one to understand as the show reminds us that
nothing ever ends. But what do you think wise crack,
let us know in the comments,
shout out to all our awesome patrons who support the channel and our podcast.
Don't forget to hit that subscribe button and we'll catch you all next time.
Peace.
[Inaudible].